hey next up you know the incredible
molly ringwald just had a birthday
and of course who could forget her
iconic character in 16 candles she
played high school kid whose entire
family forgot her birthday remember well
people reports that this year molly's
real-life mom made the same mistake that
her parents made in the movie and molly
posted their texas change it was almost
4 p.m on her birthday and then she wrote
her mom that's it you don't have
anything else to say to me oh my god
that's literally what samantha says in
the movie right and her mom her mom
texts back oh i didn't realize it was
the 18th happy birthday i haven't got
your present in the mail yet will do
very soon
ah i didn't know she's turned 54 this
year do you think in 54 years does mom
get a pass at this point
you know what's cool what um
i don't know if this matters or not but
my daughters asked me to make a wish on
my birthday this year really and i said
well do you remember the end scene of 16
candles where jake ryan asks uh samantha
go ahead make uh go ahead samantha make
a wish and she says it already came true
yes i said that's how i feel i don't
think i have anything to wish for
[Applause]
oh
but i found one anyway and made it all
right next up we've got a relationship
expert who's going viral on tick tock
for a simple little piece of advice the
new york post reports that rachel dialto
has over a million views for her video
where she says
one thing that we must normalize in
relationships is
boredom
she says all relationships get boring at
times boring moments boring nights
boring conversations and that's okay
it doesn't mean the relationship is bad
or over it's the natural ebb and flow
rossi thoughts yeah okay yeah no i don't
like
i don't like the word boring here
because there's i think the semantics
are very important right if you could
replace the word boring with comfortable
right we had a nice comfortable dinner
we had a comfortable conversation then
that's fine but if you are bored with
your partner something is up i don't
think that's great am i wrong here no
right
i know maybe the word she chose may not
be perfect but the lack of drama or
anxiety
or nerves oh my gosh doesn't that mean
something and it i don't know that's a
good point my joke about like the roller
coaster of life applies to relationships
too you're going to have ecstatic
moments exciting moments kind of lulls
and quiets and
not so exciting it just seems like
that's the way life goes like it's it's
this thank god it's not that because you
don't want that that's true that's dead
and i i would like
comfortable as you say
agreed
i agreed agreed love that all right next
up we're going to talk the latest in
fashion and the new york times style
magazine reports this spring the
hemlines are horizon with the
temperature and the mini skirt is making
a comeback look um
these teeny tiny skirts are everywhere
as we eat our pasta check out
nicole kidman is on the cover of vandy
fair's hollywood issue in a little teeny
tiny skirt now drew
are you going to be rocking a maze skirt
no no
certainly a miniskirt and a crop top
seem to be on the menu too
we'll be right back
[Music]